Tim fell of course brandy and Katherine
it's great to have you all here at ET
congratulations on everything already
winning tonight brandy it's amazing
thank you so much we are over the moon
with excitement already it's so funny
because I was privy enough to see you
come in and do a bit of rehearsal after
you'd already won a couple of awards and
you were just beaming when you hit that
stage I was crying I was crying we've
never won a Grammy Award we just won
three and it says a lot about the state
that our nation is in right now it says
a lot about the willingness to accept
the message of forgiveness and you know
political severity in this in a way I
think it's all the more important as
well because you know you really spoke
your truth and the truth that really
resonates with with us with a lot of
people around the world on this record
it's a powerful album and you've been
recognized by the Grammys which is
always a perfect combination you know
did you did you sort of feel when you
made this record that it could reach
this kind of level or were you just
hoping to get it out of your system and
just try and reach one person hoped it
would reach this level but I wasn't so
sure now I kind of like have some
restored faith yeah
so what else can you tell us about
tonight apart from obviously being
nominated you know Motown is getting
extra special recognition and rightfully
so how does it so tell us you've just
your thoughts on that and and the
importance that played on you as an
artist or all of you as people well I
think that a Motown has affected us all
deeply and particularly just
african-american music and its impact on
our country when people ask me what
makes me patriotic and what gives me a
sense of pride it's it's the fact that I
come from the place that African
American music comes from and so having
said that I'm just so looking forward to
what they have in store for us tonight
good luck tonight have a great night you
deserve it well done again questions
good to meet you
[Music]